ils sont experts comptables directrice
des ressources humaines où travaille
dans un service de paie pour un le
prélèvement à la source ce n'est pas
moins d'argent à la fin du mois mais
déjà beaucoup plus de travail depuis
longtemps et du stress si on voit si oui
si je peux pas dire qu'on aime
jean-luc wolf experts comptables suis
plus de 100 entreprises de tailles très
différentes il les accompagne dans ce
changement notamment en formation est il
en mesure le couffo c'est une vraie
contrainte supplémentaire au niveau des
entreprises pour lequel n'a eu aucune
contrepartie
par rapport à cet effort qui est fait et
qui n'amène pas de valeur ajoutée pour
l'entreprise
même du temps de gagné pour le les
services fiscaux mais absolument pas
pour les entreprises c'est une vraie
contrainte supplémentaire à leur coûte
cher
oui bien sûr puisque déjà il a fallu
changer ou modifier actualiser les les
logiciels de paye
il a donc fallu bien souvent se reformer
dessus c'est des heures et des heures à
passer parmi ses clients les salades
bregy bien connu dans le secteur de la
santé et du médico-social à besançon
c'est plus de 100 pays chaque mois et on
a fait les comptes
le personnel peine à une formation sur
le prélèvement à la source n'a eu
énormément d'heures en plus en liaison
avec ce paramétrage en liaison avec
cette préparation là et au niveau du
paramétrage du logiciel et ben ça pas
été sans frais au total depuis depuis le
mois de septembre on a dépensé 7000
euros autour de la question du prennent
un prélèvement à la source
attention tous insistent en cas de bug
le salarié doit s'adresser non pas à son
employeur met directement aux impôts